i used to think as soon as i had to
reach out in my head i was like it's
over so i'm going back downstairs i have
to go back downstairs it's over
you're not getting lips tonight
[Music]
actually no wait intro
hit me
intro hit me
patreon oh you know the vibes
you know the vibes guys you already know
the vibes guys
um
so patreon
is boogie yogi yogi now as per normal as
per normal you run over there every
thursday and you get the extra laughs
that's fifty percent of the content for
three pound a month that's all we're
asking
three pounds minimum baseline baseline
three pound a month ten p a day tempe a
day run the p m p that's it so um
hop on over there enjoy yourself live
lavish laugh it up every thursday and
you get the stuff that we're not allowed
to say on here
you get the stuff that you were not
allowed to say
and um i don't know what more you can
ask for so hop on over it's patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs enjoy
yourself
and um yeah man now we're actually going
to get into the episode we're going to
get into the episode okay let's go come
on man
um
so this fun fact is about boxing
or boxing film rocky while filming rocky
iv
um sylvester stallone asked dolph
lundgren lund gren sorry to hit him for
real
dolph agreed and then hit him so hard
that stallone had to spend nine days in
recovery in intensive care
in a later interview
dove showed no sympathy stating all i
did was obey his orders
that's the the russian guy right yeah
yeah this brother man said all i did was
obey his orders he stayed in character
he stayed in here he rocked his jaw
and sylvester stallone spent nine days
in intensive care
that's why you know you're a man's man
in it
you know you're a man's man who's
stallone or the other brother the other
guy i was gonna say rocky man's jordan
he's an intensive one bang tensive care
mad
if i was stallone and i came out after
that i'm cutting the whole movie short
i'm tearing the contracts
production now
now my life is on the line yeah to be
fair why would you say hit me for real
he he wanted to be in character i get it
i get it i get it but big man michael b
jordan got tamped up as well in korea
didn't it
by um
liverpool guy i can't remember his name
but yeah banged what the [ __ ] is his
name i don't know his name bro i i think
i know his name i just can't remember it
his name is um
he thought no he didn't um
oh i can't remember his name
i'm so bad with names people are
probably screaming it but anyway yeah
the guy from liverpool that's in creed
um
yeah he he i'm pretty sure he gave him a
concussion
banged him
but i'm not surprised getting hit by a
boxing glove
for how it feels like headache-wise is
worse than a bare fist hmm bro it rocks
i've never boxed before so i don't i
don't know how to spar
you can feel your brain
moving around
speaking of boxing did you watch the
anthony joshua fight
i was i didn't watch it live what's the
highlight i've not even seen obviously i
did watch it live i was at work but i
haven't seen any of the highest or
anything it went it went all the rounds
now
yeah
yeah
and they got time i was going to say
give me your give me your hands aj
smacked up no sympathy
sympathy i'm asking i don't know i don't
know i've not seen it all i know is they
lost he got smacked up
smacked up in that last round as well
his team threw in the towel
no but no one knows this this is the
funny thing okay no one knows this so
in the last round the last 10 seconds
aj was getting tarted up
donnie was putting paws on him yeah
tarted up and um
basically and you see the bottom left
corner of the screen the time where the
timer is
they they do the the little whatever the
signal 10 seconds 10 seconds yeah and
then although it's like a wood clap in
there
yeah yeah that's 10 seconds it says here
it goes 10
9 at 8 the graphic comes off the screen
two seconds later they ring the bell
there was five seconds left in that
round
six five five six seconds left in that
round and he was getting banged oh
really and everyone's like what the [ __ ]
happened like why would why would they
cut it short um and they're like oh
we're trying to that a lot of people the
narrative for a lot of it was they're
trying to save
face for anthony in case he was going to
get knocked out in the last few seconds
of the of the final round
but someone went to who said that
that was just the narrative in the media
okay that like they annie joshua has got
it's got such there's so many millions
of pounds wrapped around the career of
aj yeah that they can't afford him to
get knocked out in the last round mm-hmm
in the last couple ten seconds yeah yeah
yeah okay so they locked off the whole
fight a few seconds early okay so that
was the narrative but then i saw a guy
on tick tock who caught it from a
different angle
and then they look you look over aj's
corner and they're waving the towel
they're waving the towel
so that's why they i think that's why
the the bell guy saw that the ref hadn't
seen the towel the bell guy saw it and
rang the bell
um but because the ref didn't see it it
never went forward as a tko which it
should yeah yeah yeah yeah so just went
down as that's the end of the fight
say swear bro anthony got touched up
apparently
i can't remember what's this guy's name
is like you sick or something what's it
like uh yeah you sick music yeah he
apparently um he still had enough energy
to go again oh yeah he looked active he
was ready for him the thing is as well
it's tough this is
right this is the tough thing about
boxing is because for some reason
i don't know when i don't know a
roundabout
i guess it's kind of mayweather's fault
it was kind of around that mayweather
stroke um
oh god this is me with names again
um who's the guy
who's the [ __ ] druggie guy that uh
ricky hatton okay he's he's money-based
yeah
i say quite a bit i see him once again
he's fat still yeah of course
um ricky hatton yeah he was undefeated
before he fought mayweather as well okay
so around about this mayweather era
there's this boxing culture that came
around that you have to be undefeated
okay you're just no one unless you're
undefeated okay so just losing is not a
thing
but everyone lost back in the day
everyone used to lose muhammad ali lost
three times
four times
um
and there was never like a shake on his
name
he's still muhammad ali muhammad ali
lost mike tyson lost
if and holyfield's lost
uh
david haye definitely lost he's been
losing
he's been losing fram david a stays
losing
um all the greats lost um mayweather was
the only one that's like shot forward
this like narrative that like you have
to be undefeated um even though he's not
the one saying it that's just how it is
so if you're they build so much around
these boxes
uh
tyson fury wilder and aj the the three
kings
like they're fighting again this this
last week yeah yeah yeah yeah so they're
fighting again yeah well they would have
fought already by the time this comes
out but um
yeah like they're just not allowed to
lose and aj losing last time
was a shame brother yeah yeah yeah it
was a shake-up but then he came back and
wrapped him up
wrapped him up like a present
which is what i should have done yeah
yeah apparently there's going to be a
second fight
because i was well i say apparently it
who knows it was all it was all like
chinese whispers in second second ears
and stuff because i was at work one day
and coincidentally i think
maybe two or three days after the fight
the ceo of under armour and
one of the
owners of or like a high representative
maybe ceo or ceo of jd sports we're
having dinner together in my spot
um and they were just talking obviously
talking about the aj fight and blah blah
and the jd brother was like oh they're
definitely having another fight
who aj and who
this other brother that he just fought
music yeah oh yeah they will have a
fight who do you think about i thought
you were talking about the last brother
no no no no no no no no no no no yes you
said you could definitely have another
music yeah 100 yeah aj will tear them up
as well yeah that's just how aj fights
it's just like
i feel like sometimes obviously i don't
see his training camp and all this stuff
i feel like aj falls
into his own
like
how do i explain it
it's tough for aj aj has never had to
struggle
with context
he's never like aj is
aj is someone who potentially
has has the potential to be
an amazing fighter but net doesn't
hasn't necessarily had the life
experience to be one
so
if you think about aj's career right
so let's take about we'll talk about
mayweather's career versus aj's career
right okay you will know a lot more than
me i'm just right so yeah i'll talk you
through yeah right so if you look at
both of them
are like olympic athletes right
so you look at mayweather's career he's
very his career is very similar to aj's
in terms of in terms of um they were
both like
very successful amateur boxers and then
because they were so successful
were
kind of guided through their
professional career
[Music]
the difference is is
a lighter weight class
it's harder to find a guy that you can
100 smack up okay
because at the lighter weight classes
it's more skill and speed
at the you've seen some of the donuts
aj's had fights with they look like
they've never boxed before yeah yeah
that's what happens with the heavyweight
okay you're not as skilled you're strong
strong yeah but you're not a skilled i'm
just easier to be if you're a good boxer
it's easier to do well in the
heavyweight division i'm with you so
mayweather but may the difference in
mayweather is his uncle and his dad were
both ex-professional boxers he's been
boxing since he was a little kid with
professional boxers his whole life
so that's why he's one of the greatest
boxers who ever lived
aj on the other hand is a big nigerian
kid
who
obviously boxed came up the same path
everyone else did and did very well i
think he won the gold in the olympics
um in the super heavyweight division i
think it was a while back no like oh
years ago 2012 or maybe 20 years yeah
yeah
but this is the thing as well
that no one was talking about
yousick won a gold in the heavyweight
division the exact same olympics
really
oh again they're both gold medal gold
medalist olympians but you see people
talk like it's a huge upset
that
you sick beat aj
he's a gold medalist
he's a real he's the real [ __ ] deal
he's no joke
um
but anyway so
mayweather came up he's a bread boxer he
he did well i think he got silver in the
olympics okay yeah another thing you've
got he got silver in the olympics he
came up obviously he got his fights
picked for him early on et cetera et
cetera but he's picked his fights his
whole career but he is literally one of
the best boxers if not the best boxer
powerful panda who ever lived but that's
because of his upbringing
and his like
his ethos around his boxing is his life
aj is someone who's come in boxed and
taken the exact same grassroots approach
um he hasn't had boxing in his house
like his dad is not a professional boxer
who forced him to be like the prodigy
he's come up through grassroots happened
to be a big kid was probably quite
talented
and did very well in the amateurs for
his size
if you actually look at his boxing skill
and ability
take loads of weight off him he would
get destroyed in a what a lighter weight
class okay absolutely annihilated
based on his skill level
um but because he's done so well he was
a huge when he won the gold medal in the
olympics so he was scrolling a lot yeah
yeah he was a youth bro so he's been
taken from this olympic
like handsome young black uk male 1 when
the gold in the olympics they've cherry
picked him when he had way more growing
to do yeah way more growing to do to
become a better boxer and they've been
like cool fight this scrub you're better
than him fight him you're better than
him fight him you better than him fight
him you better than him he's had one or
two difficult fights in order to get the
belts he's got the belts and he's never
really had to face hardship yeah like
real hardship he's only now facing the
big boys because he's got no one left
and people are surprised why he's losing
he's like he's never had to fight anyone
hard in his entire life like if you
obviously in the amateurs and stuff i
was a kid as a grown ass man he's never
had to fight anyone like who is a
seriously skilled boxer and when he has
um
he's either had the hardest fight of his
[ __ ] life
or he's lost
and then had to come back and win which
is and then he's his very next opponent
he's lost again
and he's gonna have to come back and win
again which he will
but i feel like sometimes he falls
within the
the premise of his own narrative that
people build him up to be the best boxer
england's ever had and he is not and
that's not his fault so i don't have any
hate towards aj it's not his fault but
sometimes i feel like he falls into that
narrative and he gets a wake-up call
when he loses yeah and he comes back and
tums people up yeah which is great but
people don't give him the chance
to lose
and come back when he loses he's
forgotten and he has to seriously like
he's already on the cusp of falling out
of these three kings he's lucky that
wada and fury are fighting yeah
for the third time yeah because one of
them is losing each time yeah yeah yeah
one of them is losing each time so it
makes it even for him to lose yeah
whereas if wilder was off doing his ting
fiore fury's off doing his team
and they're not then but he's manny
losing found walden knocks people out at
one punch yeah yeah this man ain't
losing tyson fury's potentially one of
the best heavyweights who ever lived
like his skill for his size doesn't make
sense big man
these men ain't going to be losing if
they're within their own separate lanes
and then aj was just going over here
getting topped up by every tom dick and
harry aj will get slapped out of the
race
slapped out of the race fair enough it's
only because these two are fighting each
other that he's allowed to stay in this
community okay but he has the potential
but he's got like he needs like another
three four years and he's never faced
any of them too has he oh no no no no
because i know i remember wilder was
trying to get on him oh yeah both of
them are trying to get on him yeah both
of them have been trying to get him and
fury had a contract signed him and fury
had a contract signed to fight
but wilder
he was a man either like a year ago a
year and a half ago oh wow yeah he was
there when we knew we were eating yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we didn't
see him did we no
um you went to another restaurant i
remember okay
so um
yeah wilder had a rematch clause with
fury so fury wasn't allowed to fight aj
that's why they're having this they have
this fight so who won because obviously
this is their third one so i'm assuming
one one the other one was a draw and the
first one was a draw first one was draw
tyson fury smoked him in the second oh i
swear smoked him in the second one
i love how enthusiastic
this is how it was when i talk about
football so i'm loving being on the
other side of the table so this is the
thing with wilder right
terrible boxer i've seen his form like
he's like more like this
boxer he's got power he's got
more power than anyone understands yeah
he's the most powerful guy ever no one
understands why he's so strong but he
has ridiculous knockout power so he just
catches you and that's your soul it's
done
but he cannot box for [ __ ] so the first
one
fury was just so scared about getting
knocked out that he wasn't fighting that
game okay but fury still technically in
my opinion on points fury beat him in
the first one okay he still topped him
up in the first one but he got knocked
down twice maybe three times in the
first uh fight so points wise that
balanced out the score for the judges to
pass out so they they locked it up as a
draw and while i didn't get knocked down
once at all now why didn't get knocked
down at all
tyson stayed getting knocked down okay
that right it doesn't make sense when he
hits you with the right yeah you're out
it doesn't matter who you are i need to
watch the two again before watching yeah
the second fight though fury realized oh
this guy can't actually do [ __ ] he
especially can't fight off his back foot
if you put him on the back foot he can't
do anything so all the second fight
tyson uh fury was moving forward forward
forward forward thumping him up him up
smacked him in that second fight so in
my opinion he smacked him in the first
fight but he kept knocking you down then
you chomped him up again didn't get
knocked down at all in the second fight
and now he should have wrapped it up
from there should have been like you got
timed up the first one but you got lucky
second one i'll definitely trumped you
up let's just leave it there but now he
said now third one let's run it back a
third time so who agreed for this so
both this was already in their contract
from from the first jump from either the
first or the second i don't know
but um i think it might have been from
the first i think it was a two rematch
clause in the first one jesus
um because for these man it makes sense
because for these these are their
career-high fights it's the most money
they're ever going to make on a fight
and they don't know what their career is
going to look like afterwards yeah i've
not thought about it that way before but
if you think about it since tyson fury
beat wilder who's given a [ __ ] about
wilder no one no one knows what world
has been doing with his career since he
got tumped up by fury last time so this
is why they have all these rematch
clauses okay all these rematch clauses
because it's like
you work all your whole career and then
you have these
guys these top three four guys and you
once you've made your way through those
your career is done
if you're not the guy who won all of
them your career is done
tyson fury's gonna beat both of them
uh he's gonna beat wada and he's gonna
be aj aj is loved so much in this
country that he might be fine afterwards
wilder probably not
but he'll have more money than he ever
needs anyway but tyson fury is also old
mm-hmm actually how old is tyson he
looks [ __ ]
yeah but the thing is the only thing
with tyson um
fury is that uh let's have a look see
tyson
fury
age
oh it's 33. he's kind of odd
ajs they won the other state five wow
they're old they're all old dionte
wilder didn't start boxing till he was
like 20.
and he
got silver medal of the olympics gold
medal in the olympics oh wow deontay
wilde was crazy
so it's not
for deontay it's not more about the
skill it's just more the power because
he can't
he has no skill i've seen him box like a
few times yeah well not like a whole
match but like different rounds or like
different like snippets on like socials
and stuff yeah yeah and the way he
swings doesn't make sense sometimes
and obviously he's like six five six six
so he's armed he's reaches disgraceful
all power guys uh
just real quick
i just want to take a quick second
to shed some love on the boys over at
manscapade you know the vibes
so over at manskapade they're doing real
interesting [ __ ] man
and this time of year
with all the the the spooky scares that
are going around
bro
don't let your lady get a scare at home
in our own bed
don't let her get scared don't let her
go under the covers and be frightened no
you don't want to have you don't want to
see jack the ripper like that fam no we
don't need all that nah cousin it
just chilling ah chilling just following
she's trying to run out
no you don't need that we need smooth
sailing around here smooth sailing sir
uh gents jump in
all you need to do is you want to scurry
over to your laptop in the middle of the
night in the dead of night sneak on over
to that laptop you go over to
manscape.com
you pick up the [ __ ]
performance package 4.0 it's the fourth
generation performance package bro you
get yourself some of those sleeky
smooth boxes best boxes ever best boxes
ever test date boxes today i'm wearing
them now
i am wearing them now best boxers gang
there you go
smooth ass boxes
with that
disgracefully accurate skin smooth
um
well auntie trimmer oh the trimmer you
can talk about the anti-chafing boxes no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no natural trimmer itself trimmer
itself yeah and some of you might be
thinking but james i don't like my [ __ ]
skin fresh i like a little bit of
gristle
that's fine that's fine because they got
the adapters it comes with the heads bro
like just like when you go to the
barbers and you get like one point five
or a two and a fade drum
down yourself a fade you can do your own
fade for yourself yeah it's it's it's
about so um jump in the code is sngc
every november golf
that's 20 off you get free shipping
manscape.com let's not even talk about
it anymore just do it we're not all
about talk we're about actions
the sng crew about actions not talk so
head on over let us know what you think
and uh before further ado yes get back
in the episode man let's go and going
all pal but i think he's gonna
yeah i don't know man he there so that's
what it is they've got all these rematch
clauses because once you make your way
through the top guys
if you come up at the bottom your career
is pretty much done really kind of
because especially at that age he's 35
years old of that obviously at that age
he can only fight people lower than him
now he can't carry enough he's not the
champion
so he's not going to get another
championship if you fought so let's say
you're deontay wilder let's say you for
um this is awkward because
the fight actually hasn't happened yet
but when this airs the fight will have
happened
so i don't know if he's lost or why okay
but i know what you mean yeah but let's
say in retrospect let's say you are
dying to water and you've lost to tyson
fury
um for the second time now at the third
fight
so
you're not going to get another shot at
him
he's the champion now and you're not
you're not going to get another chance
um well he's already the champion and
you're not you take your last chance
you lose again
he's never ever going to give you
another chance why would he why would he
so now you can only fight people below
you
and you're only getting older and
they're getting better so every fight
that you have below you people pay less
and less to see because they don't
actually care
and you the only way you can make it big
money is if you fight the hardest
up-and-comer coming up
and he may not even want to fight you
yet and if he does want to fight you
he might trump you up so it's a risk
every single time and you're already 35.
damn
yeah the life of a fighter is not nice
bro
damn and then you've got the aj side
same again aj
aj has to avoid those man as long as he
can
and the best thing you want to do is
avoid them so long that when you finally
do fight them like let's say he fighting
fights tyson fury he wants to fight
tyson fury when tyson fury's like out
of his prime
he wants to fight tasman foreign is in
terrible shape he's just had his third
mental breakdown this year
he's had another six kids
fight him then yeah that's when you want
to fight him
if you're aj
and that's kind of what mayweather did a
lot for his career as well oh really
he fought so um you know
thank you canelo alvarez
canelo yes yes yes yes yes along with
mayweather debatably
going fast
he's got speed speed and [ __ ] power
i've seen him on the bags speed i've
seen him he's a talented youth fan yeah
i've seen him on the back he got topped
up by mayweather when he was a kid okay
when he was up and coming mayweather
knew he was going to be the [ __ ] so
mayweather would never fight him once he
was good yeah he also mayweather also
for oscar de la hoya okay when oscar de
la hoya was past his prime
would never fight
oscar de la hoya in this prime he
probably still would have beat him in my
opinion i've seen a lot of oscar de la
hoya fights i've seen a lot of advice i
still think maybe we would have beat
oscar de la hoya but it's just not worth
it it's not worth the risk mayweather
has never taken a risk in his entire
career
he doesn't take risks like that they're
all or they're always calculators okay
and that's why he's rich as [ __ ] yeah he
makes your bets he makes sure yeah he
makes sure because why wouldn't you
because he's in it for the p even though
he's talented he's got this talent and
he's like i'm gonna make
so much money out of this it doesn't
make sense and at the same time i'm also
not gonna get my head caved in um
so yeah he made himself like
easily the best defensive boxer who ever
lived
even if he's not the best boxer overall
he's the best defensive boxer who ever
lived he always makes calculated risks
and fights the best fighters
at their worst time
if he fought for though if he fought al
uh canelo in his prime
canelo would wipe the [ __ ] floor with
him when would you say canelo's prime
was or is i don't know now really for
the last three years if he would have
fought him three years ago when
mayweather was still kind of active uh
same another one manny pacquiao he
fought mania pacquiao when he had like a
broken arm
manu pacquiao was [ __ ] when he fought
him and that was such a sought after
fight because manny pacquiao was a
killer yeah a [ __ ] killer a filipino
[ __ ] killer
ah maybe i didn't want any part of it
yeah yeah yeah waited until he [ __ ]
his arm up yeah and then was like let's
scrap come let's go let's go oh handicap
fam it was a boring fight as well boring
fight pacquiao couldn't do [ __ ]
mayweather was just playing it safe
boring fight
yeah bro
yeah yeah yeah mayweather does he's not
stupid
and he's talented enough that no one can
say with chest so even though he's
cherry-picking all his fights yeah no
one can say that even if he wasn't
anyone could do himself anyway because
he's so good
um
but yeah canelo alvarez
in his prime
he'd swallow mayweather
he'd swallow him fam
canelo is a [ __ ]
animal
he's he's he's fighting people like
three weight classes above him really
obviously he has the meat weight yeah of
course bro he's [ __ ] up like light
heavyweights what's his regular thingy
regular weight loss like welterweight oh
really something ridiculous like that
something ridiculous like that oh wow
he's he's mopping people up oh wow did
you see his press conference the other
week no i don't follow him like that
well i don't follow but i just saw him
take time i didn't even follow it much
i'm sorry tick tock okay fam
um
he smacked one guy in a press conference
but it was like oh
it split his eye open he's fighting a
guy they were having a face off
and the guy said something and um canelo
alvarez doesn't speak any english okay
he's mexican doesn't speak any [ __ ]
english which is ridiculous at this
level it's ridiculous but whatever yeah
um and the guy said something to him and
he thought he was saying something about
his mum
[Music]
so the guy said something he thought was
saying something about his mom canada
alvarez pushed him the guy said yeah
swung for him canela alvarez gave him a
quick slip as he slipped smacked no he
actually punched him gave him a quick
slip bang
lightning fast
lightning fast whack that
guy came up i'm bleeding
[ __ ] cause i was ready
in a press conference suit and tie [ __ ]
gave him a slip and a bang i was like oh
my god he stays ready oh my god fam he's
a [ __ ] anal he would destroy
mayweather destroy him
if it was prime and prime i actually
don't know yeah it'll be the fight
of a century
canelo in his prime versus mayweather in
his prime
the fight of a [ __ ] lifetime that no
one knows who will win
i love the enthusiasm bro i love it i'm
here
i'm envisioning it all and my only
actual because i don't follow boxing
that much i just know a few names here
and there and i see a couple fights or a
couple um highlights and replays
my only
true not necessarily i wouldn't say true
reference but my only um other reference
point is anime hajime no ippo
so oh yeah so when you're talking about
like slips in yeah i'm watching i'm
imagining my man i'm like yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] it oh yeah damage roll damage
yeah yeah yeah that would be the fight
of a century
um speaking of fighting there was a
fight a couple weeks ago
uh brian ortega
versus
alex uh volkanovsky volkanovsky polish i
something like that bro
probably the best fighter of mma i've
ever seen
probably the best fight
of mma i've ever [ __ ] seen bro
talk to me
oh
so
these men must be so bored if they don't
like fighting
they'll get used to it so check this out
so it's hard if you don't understand jiu
jitsu it's hard but basically if you
take brian ortega who's a great fighter
really really really good at jiu-jitsu
really good at jesus so it's
i actually don't know but he's
definitely black yeah um so in terms of
submissions catching you and stuff like
that
given the opportunity he's gonna snap
you up yeah volkanovsky is just an
overall he's a champion overall beast
overall beast bro
so you're in there is this heavyweights
by the way no no no no this is 100 and
oh
they're quite light i want to say either
155 maybe 170
and
they're in there
they're going
volkanovsky's
tamping
his head in
so accurately that it's concerning
it doesn't matter where ortega goes he's
teeing off on his head
ortega's face is disheveled
it's swollen in places that don't make
sense yeah it's lost shape
and he's teeing off on his head like
it's a a speed bag yeah
and he's clocking him back
and then
just as you're watching it in the third
round you're like ortega's done yeah but
he's fighting for his life he's standing
and he's swinging and you're thinking i
give ratings to ortega yeah but it's a
wrap yeah you're a few seconds from
getting dropped fam out of nowhere he
throws his right hand
ortega throws his right hand puts
volkanovsky on his ass
and then goes in for a mounted
guillotine from standing so basically
what that means is
if i'm sat down here yeah half lying
down you say you just put me on my arse
yeah i'm sat down i'm kind of half lying
half yeah um trying to get up yeah so my
head's here yeah my hands are here yeah
yeah i can envision it
you leap on top of me yeah
so you're face to face on top of me
mounted so he's sitting on top of him
he grapevined him which means he wrapped
his legs under here
so you're on top of me and you wrap your
legs under my legs so he can't get up
there so he can't get up and you've got
me in a headlock
so forward forward
mounted guillotine
forward headlock
and chokes the living [ __ ] out of him
out of it was like in a split second if
you had a split second dropped him and
he leapt on in like a tiger
it's such a complex move to do that you
would never do it from a standing
position yeah you don't leap on someone
like that
i've never seen anything like it
you'd have to show me a kid i'll show
you tonight is everything don't leap on
someone like that stop it
i couldn't believe my eyes swam
i physically couldn't believe my eyes
yeah and he
locked it in bro
you volcano was gargling he said after
the fight he said he was gargling
he locked it the [ __ ] but it takes so
much arm strength to try and choke the
life out of someone like that that if
you can hold out long enough you can
survive it right somehow volkanovsky
didn't tap out oh really even though he
was choking so much that spit was coming
out of his mouth
eventually he loosened the grip a little
bit because he couldn't because he
couldn't keep his bicep was pretty
cramping yeah couldn't keep it wasn't
just got out
got out we returned to our feet and we
go again
teeing off on his head again now volcano
have seen vex yeah of course that's teen
off in his head again
i think either the third round or the
fourth round
drops ortega
revenge time fam and you're like it's a
wrap someone's throwing the towel
because ortega's face is [ __ ] yeah
he's just been getting ruined this whole
fight he had that one chance with the
with the mountain guillotine it's it's
done now yeah it's done vodka gets him
down
the ground and pound
whack
whack and you're just like ref stop it
yeah please
it's a general see this is general
health and safety now fam
as he as he goes in to land the
finishing blow ortega grabs his arm gets
him in a triangle so a triangle
so a triangle
is where say okay it's really hard to
demonstrate but basically you you've
captured one arm yeah so i'm laying down
yes so you're laying down you're trying
to punch me on a punchy yeah you've
you've captured one of his arms right
yeah you're holding on to that yeah
so you get one leg
on the trap
of the arm that he got no the other arm
oh the other arm that you don't have so
i'm sorry with the left for example if
you've got if you've got his right arm
yeah you've got this arm on this side
it'll be the left you've taken your left
leg and you've got it on your trap yeah
and that's wrapped around that now so
he's got this arm free this side yes
you're not touching it yes on his left
trap yes and you bent your knee so your
legs in a right angle like this your
your hamstrings on his trap and your
lower legs right around the back of his
leg
back of his legs back of his neck oh
sorry sorry sorry sorry sam your
hamstring's on his trap yep angled your
leg this way i can see it and your calf
is on the back of his neck i can see it
and your heel is on the other side of
his shoulder i can see it i can see it
you've now locked this arm yeah and
you've locked his head down are you
pulling him you're pulling it towards
you and then you get your other leg and
you cross your legs over like this like
this yeah yeah in a triangle position
okay clamp down and you choke the [ __ ]
out of him with your legs
you've got one arm here to stop him
getting away
and you've got your his head
in between your legs and you're
squeezing your legs together for dear
life to choke him to death
he caught him in it
caught a minute just as he was about to
get knocked the [ __ ] out caught him in
there again gargling for life
volcanos he's gargling for life again
again
after he's been winning this whole fight
two separate occasions he's nearly done
somehow
get out of it again no way and bruno
bryant's jujitsu is fantastic you don't
get out of these things
once he's got it locked in you don't get
out yeah he survived it again bro again
and then for the rest of that round
teed the [ __ ] off on his head again
revenge style started thumping the [ __ ]
out of ortega again jesus
the fifth round everyone was like enough
is enough if you look at ortega's head
he looks like he's got elephant titus
geez his face is [ __ ]
the ref is the doctor's talking to him
he can't answer questions correctly he
don't know where he is he gets up in the
fifth round and everyone's like nah stop
the fight fam stop the fight it's done
you had your two chances to submit him
valiant effort but he didn't get it and
we're sorry for you but you didn't get
it bro
ortega comes out dizzy in that round
volkanovsky's tired but he knows he's
won this fan goes for a swing swing
ortega slip slip whack
whack whack ortega is coming out guns
blazing fou had
whack whack whack whack what can i ask
you notices the last round so he's like
yeah yeah doing the little yeah whack
what
fam he shudders back he shudders back
tries to get his arms up
starts
chomping the [ __ ] out of him ortega's
going nuts yeah from where he got this
energy i don't know yeah whack whack
whack the whole time fam
bell rings everyone's everyone's in
there
yeah yeah yeah blood everywhere the dogs
are good as [ __ ]
up
luckily volkanovsky because vanessa
vodka because voguenoski tom come up for
the entire fight he wins the fight but
ortega goes out on his shield fam
he goes out and she just collapses gets
dragged out the thing
best mma fight i've ever seen in my life
wow i've never seen anything like it
every time he was about to go snapped
him in some elite jiu jitsu
elite jiu jitsu couldn't believe it you
just describing it oh i was there i felt
like i was ringside
i felt like i was ringside phenomenal it
sounded like it was fantastic
oh
creme de la creme of fighting gang
creme de la creme
just to be able to watch that fight and
appreciate that fight
made it worth
the [ __ ] two
years you've done yeah yeah just to
understand how difficult that is to do
yeah i couldn't believe it that's going
that gear team
i gasped when i saw it it just mounted
he lept on him i'll show you that he
leapt on him oh i need to see that he
couldn't see
we're gonna get into the juice
um
because
so if you guys have been sticking with
us for the last few weeks
you'll know that we'll be going back and
forth with who gives what the ick oh
yeah guys
girls give us the ick here
and uh foo had did a little post on
instagram a couple weeks ago yeah of
what gives girls the ick what gives guys
the ick and we're gonna reel off some of
the highlights
um
and we're just going to put this [ __ ]
to bed yeah so which one do you want to
go for first goes on guys
let's do
guys first and then we'll roll onto the
we'll end off with the ladies all right
cool
so the things that give guys the ick
um one when she plays the game better
than you
that's sticky wow okay a lot of these
ones are the ones i never replied to on
on instagram okay
there were quite a few that i didn't see
until later on
some guy said when she doesn't watch
anime which is jokes um
definitely when the little kids are
running around me and they're trying to
touch my [ __ ]
what why are you even in that situation
look
what so he's saying what gives him the
ick about girls said when her little
kids are around me
trying to touch my [ __ ]
i mean that's just your problem oh wow
that's not even a nick
that's just your personal problem yeah
this one for me is key girls with no
rhythm
for me it's the worst it's you know
i know who you're telling you know what
i'm talking about
she's
like you can't be peng with no rhythm it
just
bang it just doesn't add up to me i
haven't seen this obviously no rhythm
thing that you're talking about but from
the pictures you showed me 10 out of 10
banging it just doesn't add up to me
broski it's not fair it's not oh no
rhythm girls with no rhythm are the
worst
are the worst yeah that gives me
superior ick oh man
you might not have it i saw one of them
on there mm-hmm that said
when she looks like she smells ham
fam
i don't know if this is related to what
he was talking about yeah
but there are some
like obese chicks i've seen in my day
and i've got nothing wrong with
overweight females
but there's some oh bees chicks are seen
in the day i'm just like i know she
stinks
just from looking at her i know she
stinks and then she might come and try
chat to me or something
and ham is a very particular way to
describe it
ham is a very particular way to describe
it
but i know exactly what he's talking
about she stinks just like that just
like what i feared she would
ham you know oh that is
that's not on that's not on
um
some people when she has hygiene that
makes no sense
having to use a condom
is what ah that's a controversial ick
but that's a controversial egg i know
[Laughter]
um someone else put false advertising in
leggings
i've been there back in the day been
there
what are you saying
i've got a legging ick okay
baggy leggings big man
are the biggest ick i've ever
experienced
baggy leggings it's not cute
do you remember jeggings
jeggings were the worst thing that ever
created yeah worst thing ever created
ah they used to run a muck in my school
back a day bro bro bro speaking of leg
and stroke jegan x do you remember
ah do you remember yeah the the girl
this was the ick for me you know like
the female school trousers yeah the
tight ones yeah
when
they were stretch out and the glue used
to separate out of the seam in the body
yeah yeah that gave me massive
the glue strands used to be straight you
just look like fibers yeah just spraying
out the back i know what you mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't know
what it used to be mad egg
ah i know what you mean i know what you
mean
um
those mercury in retrograde girls
blaming crystals on their bad vibes
[Laughter]
mercury and retrograde oh that's jokes
that made my eye hurt
blaming crystals on their bad vibes
funny
that's funny that is hilarious
them you can't handle me girls oh yeah
non-toxic girls man likes a toxic [ __ ]
once someone put when they catch me
cheating
ah
nah that's sour
fam
when girls get makeup on your hoodie or
top was that for me
yes it issue
it's an issue this is the issue that for
me is an issue
like when you're hugging a chick and you
just get the makeup here on your breast
or your shoulder pisses me off
pisses me off i don't know if i call her
egg but it pisses me the [ __ ] off pisses
me off
it pisses me i just want to [ __ ] off
grab her i want to touch her foot like
this and dash it
trying to [ __ ] dash it but [ __ ]
hug me again yeah
oh girls with [ __ ] tan on their hands oh
their hands and their hands are like the
ankle area here oh the hands the ankle
area under the nails
yeah
it can help that is a nick icky now that
isn't [ __ ] ick bro
anyway
uh girls with nasty feet he said he
doesn't like feet by girls with nasty
feet in general yes
when girls just use men for their cars
if the sunshine is at their ass oh i
like it
bitter as well but girls do do that
when she's thai and has a bigger dick
than you
wow jesus
that little moustache i pretend not to
notice
dread
man sent for it dread
oh wow
that's actually dread oh wow
ah oh
when she wants to finger me
that's
that's a lot
yeah the wonder you said girls that look
like they smell like ham that's it
oh god someone put girls fighting in
general oh yeah
that would make me ick
um
i know oop like man you're trying to
catch this hook
something i hate when people say oop
when they expect you to pay for
everything i want to be living top tier
hairy females where are they getting the
[ __ ] from where are you meeting these
women i don't know why are you meeting
these women
um
screeching when they see their friends
they haven't seen in a long time yeah
yeah yeah
girls whose breath stink
no aspirations or ambitions shoreditch
[ __ ] yep
ick
[ __ ]
sainsbury's you know
wow
oh when a girl asks or says if she's
prettier than her then your ex or then
my ex for example who says that
that's a teenage thing there's a
teenager for sure that's a teenage thing
for sure for sure for sure
um who would ask that am i prettier than
your ex
shut up fam
you are my ex
that's what i'm saying
you are my ex
it's the
dash for me
makes me want to be celibate it's the
whatever for me big man did we not say
that last time have we said that before
or no i can't i don't know did i just
read that one
it was on the thing that i put on
yeah it's the difference [ __ ] hate
that top three i [ __ ] hate that bro
three top three top three top three top
three top three oh yeah top three
oh my days
um
this is one i put up as well on the day
when her titties don't bounce when she's
on top that that sweetened me that's
harsh that's harsh but it's sweet at me
yeah yeah
harsh but sweet me all right cool let me
do the woman all right women they're
going to send for us i know they are
they always do
they they always women hit mad specific
yeah they they cut
it's cutthroat yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's um yeah it's no it's no game um
when they come and don't bother making
us come then cuddles like nothing
happened
pooh attached in the man's bum here and
they'll wipe the ass problem and they
don't wipe the ass properly saw that
saw that
saw that and creased
poo in their bum hair
yeah that's it
dot com sng twenty percent off free
shipping worldwide there you go
there you go no you can tell me i've got
[ __ ] in my ass
no you can tell me i've got [ __ ] in my
ass
i'll kill myself
i'll kill myself who had ah
you got snap
i hate
that's what girls want you got a snap i
[ __ ] hate
snapchat
and
sorry just to bring it back i've just
had i've just had one that it's an ick
for me yeah
i think we spoke about on here before
when they stopped contributing to the 69
i don't know if you've had that idea
when they stop contributing to the 69
because they want to knock yeah nah
suck me off in it
it's a 69 for a reason damn
[Laughter]
children with their mouth open want
another
one
that's kind of yucky that is yucky
this is a bigger for me i think i put
top three on this when girls walk around
um barefoot at the end of the night that
is that for me
wait i thought we'd be doing the girls
ones
[ __ ] oh yeah we are but this this is
what annoyed me on the day okay
when i put
um
whoever anyone was contributing and i
wasn't replying to the mandate yeah they
got carried off because i've i've saved
all of them yeah yeah yeah
they got carried away oh that drives me
insane yeah i'm specifically saying i
understand the assignment exactly know
your assignment man um
when he takes pictures using famous
tourist attractions as his dick
that's very specific
uh-huh
so i'm assuming for example
um when he takes famous when he takes
pictures using famous tourist
attractions as his dick i'm super for
example like the eiffel tower and you'll
say oh this is the size of everything i
don't know
i don't know
because that's very specific so she's
obviously talking about something crazy
specifically yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um
when he says i thought you were younger
you look 16 why are you asking for man
snap what
motorbike thieves oh no that's a guy a
guy wrote that [ __ ] hell you guys
don't understand the assignment
oh double texting if you're not my man
that's um that's a good one i like that
one i like that one double texting if
you're not my man
i like that
i like my younger years i found myself
double texting and as soon as you see it
that blue blue you're like what a vibe
done
i'll take it back
it looks hideous yeah
it literally looks hideous it's not a
good look it's not a good look
um
when his moans sound like a 12 year old
girl getting punched on the upper arm
instant dessert
[Laughter]
oh wow
oh that's funny
when he immediately likes everything i
say like he has no personality or
opinion yeah that's a good one that's a
very good one that's [ __ ] valid
that's a very very good one um
full mirror selfie nudes or nudes with
his face in it understandable news with
his face that's such a preach you know
i hear you nudes with his face in it
uh desperately begging me to tell him
he's good during it even that made me
say her
like nah you need your ego is off my
jeep yeah yeah yeah your ego is off
um
this is one for me male or female being
rude to servers says a lot about someone
if they're not polite to everyone hey
that for me is a huge ick disgraceful oh
that drives me insane yeah it describes
me insane graceful
that drives me insane
um
i can finally try and find a good one
when he's trying to pick something up
but it blows slash rolls away
oh this is what i mean bro when girls go
for the throat yeah they they slice it
open
that's not fair fault fab i can see it
little piece of paper and you're going
to get it and it blows away just nah and
she looks at it it says yeah
yeah i remember reading one this is a
while back
where it says
um you know when you go on trains and
the train stops and you jolt they said
if you if you're jolting you're not my
man
you're not my man
you're not my man that's not fair it's
not fair brother that's not fair that's
how i used to feel when i was younger i
would get on the bus and you know when
the bus starts moving and it kind of
peels back yeah yeah yeah and your walls
say if you're walking to the upstairs
and you see the man and the gala sitting
there and the bus takes off and you have
to reach to grab something
i used to think as soon as i had to
reach out in my head i was like it's
over so i'm going back downstairs i have
to go back downstairs it's over
you're not getting lips tonight nowhere
near you're getting tonight
when they say you remind them of their
mum
specific boy
have you ever said that to a girl you
remind me of your mother my mum
nah i don't think so i i know i haven't
said that
that is
i would i've said to women
like you're such a mum yeah in terms of
the what they yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
my mom that's
that's um yeah that's a lot
um
guys just staring at me makes me angry
i mean it depends on how they're staring
at you
it does
when he seemingly skips his hands and
ankles when applying body lotion
wow
i think i saw that one
i think i saw that one
imagine just walking around
with actually hand at your cream to the
gills
hands and feet and ankles are ash
oh it's embarrassing have you seen this
week enough
there's this interviewer right he
interviews nba players okay some mexican
guy oh definitely and he always asks and
lebron james was ducking him for years
okay and he always asks do you wash your
legs in the shower
thus we ask everyone okay do you wash
your legs in the shower
okay because i'm gonna come out and say
it
i barely wash my legs in the shower i
wash my legs what do you mean like
actual like soap and water like get in
the like okay so when i'm in the shower
yeah
i do face i've got a specific face
cleanser yeah same face yeah rinse it
out yeah then i get my body wash yeah i
do
arm
pit pit
torso yeah
and like quads yeah i don't lift up my
leg to do this i just don't okay i just
don't okay so
when when
when he asked lebron james yeah do you
oh and balls okay cotton balls yeah when
he asked lebron james oh do you wash
your legs in the shower it sweetened me
fat
it sweeted me why because he i don't
and i was like you want to say yes
but you're like
i bet bear if i don't do it yeah and
this johnny's asking if lebron james
does it yeah i'm thinking i bet hardly
anyone does it i do
but use a glove don't you yeah i've seen
in your shower use a glove using
exfoliating gloves that makes sense yeah
i i don't i use it with my hands
um
so yeah i'm interested in the comments
mandem own up
own up
send an emoji if you have
do you mind wash your lower leg i'm not
bringing up my knee in the shower like a
yeah i'm not bringing up my knee in the
shower i'm not bending over to my legs
i'm not raising my leg i'm bending my
back in the shower that's jokes
every time you use the word tar it
sweets me bro you have no idea sweet
sweet oh wow like a tart oh this one's
sweetened me as well when he's got some
orange left in the corner of his mouth
after eating bolognese
[Laughter]
i've seen that
random that's a white guy thing
in terms of i've only ever seen it in
white guys oh really
i don't think i've ever seen that period
have you not i don't think so i've seen
it i don't think i've seen it when they
sucked the spaghetti yeah
yeah about their bolognese sauce in my
corner it's
butters that's hilarious
oh my days um
when you're giving him a [ __ ] and he
smells of [ __ ]
fam someone's put that before
i've seen that before a while ago
what is that
this car relates to the [ __ ] in the bum
hair thing as well
when you're giving him a [ __ ] he
smells like [ __ ]
oh dear personal hygiene is uh oh dear
imagine
and she must have wanted to knock him
out just in his torso just
fam [ __ ] must want to knock him out his
[ __ ] chest imagine eating a girl out
and you can smell physical human [ __ ]
i'll be i would be so angry
so would i i'd be so [ __ ] so would i
so would i
so would i
when he moans louder than me
i've seen that by like what
what i don't know
because how are you moan i i don't moan
i don't mind
so i don't know i don't know maybe some
some guys might
um men in flip-flops
jokes
want to see the white crap in the corner
of the mouth when they're talking i'll
just like dry them out yeah dry them out
corner
is that it yeah there's loads but that's
right that's cool yeah oh man
apparently there's bad things that give
people ick
there are i'm still scrolling there's
loads i'm not sad there's
so
there's one that no
i don't think any girl has ever said but
it has to be an ick because i refuse to
be seen in this situation
a man
naked with nothing on but a t-shirt
has to be king of the egg oh that's i
don't think that's normal
that's not normal
funny enough i've seen i can't remember
we must have been on tick tock because
for the life i can't remember who it was
but
for some reason someone was asking
someone else it could have been a
podcast okay someone was asking someone
else what's your getting ready routine
and man said he puts his socks on
and then he puts his shirt on afterwards
well like he's tough but after no i
don't know that's unacceptable what
that's unacceptable
what that's unacceptable that makes no
sense brother
what's your getting ready routine boxes
then socks boxes boxes boxes on first of
all especially well
i'm talking about my routine if i'm
going to work okay not in general let's
just say if i'm going to work boxes
socks
trousers and then a top top is always
the last thing i wear
okay
fair play
okay cool what's yours mine is
top is always the last thing i wear
as well exactly no okay
mine on a casual thing
because it's interesting you said about
work actually sorry to cut you off
regardless of casual or not i think it's
the same regardless okay
mine's different if i'm wearing a shirt
or not
an actual button shirt an actual body
if i'm wearing like
office attire like shirt and trousers
i will go
boxers
socks
shirt
and then trousers because trying to tuck
a shirt into
is as long doing trousers and then
putting on a shirt and trying to tuck it
in is gay
i know and then trying to get your socks
on when you're when your shirt is tucked
and your belt is done yeah trying to get
socks on yeah it's impossible yeah yeah
the thing's falling out everywhere yeah
yeah so yeah if i'm wearing smart attire
that's how i do it if i'm on a casual
thing i go boxers
trousers
socks
top
if i'm wearing shorts i think my socks
would be last up no not last but i'll be
boxers then shorts yeah then i'll wear
my socks but regardless of the attire or
whatever my top is always lasting yeah
i'm pretty sure my top's always lasting
always but boxes first and then socks as
i have a second or third most likely
second calm but yeah for my man to wear
socks and then the top so he's mid rift
to just hang in it makes no
sense you have no order in your life i'm
just disgusted you have no order that's
disgusting
it's just your wife can't walk in on you
and your dick's hanging between the two
little flaffles of your shirt
you waste man
you waste it makes no sense flaccid tall
it's hanging it just makes
um
but yeah uh let's do it by the [ __ ]
let's so i said okay boys huge fan of
the pod been about since november sort
of time and i have a bit of a dilemma
stroke am i the [ __ ]
so i'm 19 years old and because of that
i missed my whole 18th year to be going
clubbing and finding my feet in the
excuse
streets
boys
that's changed now he said
i don't know how because i got big
confidence issues but i'm having tings
throw themselves at me with barely
trying my my boys keep getting facts
i'm from james's old ends so there's
only really one spot i can go for a
night out
and because of this the tings um you're
old and what's your old dance
i'm not really shorty okay
but i've lived in sticks so it wouldn't
surprise me if there's only one spot i
can come out
uh there's only one real spot i can go
out for a night out and because of this
the things i'm banging are all out in
the same spot and while other girls try
and move me ultings have seen me moving
reckless
it's rookie it's dangerous
so i want to see how this plays out i've
had birds come up to me calling me a
dirty sleazy bastard
throwing drinks etc no that's long yeah
so my question is am i the [ __ ] for
not explaining to the birds what it
really is between us or should they
understand from the fact they
come up to me and basically drag me back
to their yard
also over the last weekend i've patted
three best friends from friday to sunday
and a four-way thing is in the works
you're a liar you're a liar the last bit
is just for bragging rights i won't lie
love the pod keep doing what you're
doing um to answer the question about
what say the actual am i the author for
thing again because i hadn't so is he
the [ __ ] for not explaining to the
girls when he's banging them hey this is
just a smash and next weekend i will be
out pulling next considering because he
said considering they're basically
he's basically saying he's meeting them
on the night out and they're just
dragging him back to yard the thing i've
had this to me before not necessarily
with random chicks but with people i've
seen in the past and have had sex with
them later on in life
um
when
sorry how so
i'm gonna expect okay sorry um
when in my opinion
if a guy has sex with a girl
especially he said he's about 18 19 19
19. i feel like
a sense of entitlement comes with it
from a female perspective i know what
you mean so
if they've had
sometimes in a girl's mind in my opinion
once you've had sex with them especially
at that age like i said the sense of
entitlement comes into play so in their
heads once this nut is bus
this is us now we're gonna be [ __ ]
now they own you exactly but long story
short they own you yeah so for them to
see you next week with a next thing
in the same gaffe oh their world is
rocked yeah yeah the world is rocked in
a bad way yeah you know so that's the
reason why i won't necessarily say
you're the [ __ ] for not explaining to
them
but they also
it's a double-edged sword because they
have to understand the situation which
i'm assuming they're they've not been in
that position yet to understand like
they need to know that
[ __ ] has consequences you can't just
come up to me as a man and be like yo
i'm trying to [ __ ] what are you trying
to i'm only human
i'm going to say yes i'm 19 brother yeah
yeah yeah especially if you're looking
banging i'm 19. i'm trying to yes come
let's go let's do it now so
um within the same breath sometimes you
should
you should not necessarily explain
yourself
but if you can see
they're trying to make it more than what
it is then you'll be like oh by the way
like we're just trying yeah i mean it's
a tough one i agree like it's one of
them ones and things as well but as you
were explaining it
i thought yeah that is a female thing
but then i thought it's kind of a guy
thing i was just about to say it goes
both ways it does go both goes because
same way like
if he if i not me specifically but even
i can see it if i was to put a girl on a
night out in a specific spot and then
the very next weekend i saw her moving
to another guy in the same spot knowing
i'm there i would be a bit like
this is the game we're in
these streets are reckless but i think
the difference is the difference between
men and women in my opinion is we would
just firm the hell yeah i know that's my
pride talking and not her issue yeah and
i would just get on one yeah we firm the
elders move on yeah because
we're not trying to create scenes like
that yeah we had fun we both did the
dance and we moved on yeah she clearly
moved yeah yeah yeah and i'm just here
picking up scraps yeah but the game is
literally the game yeah it's unfair and
that's just the way the cookie crumbles
yeah i don't know it's a bit
it's one of them ones as well that you
also have to accept the role that you're
in yeah like
it's one of the ones that if you're not
gonna tread softly because clearly
you're not treading softly
and the fact of the matter is is that
especially that age
having sex is even if it's a minor it's
also not a minor to these girls yeah and
if you're gonna
run reckless like you said yourself if
you're gonna move reckless and move to
separate things
even in the within the same friendship
group in the same spot week after week
after week you have to expect some kind
of repercussions you don't just get to
live rent free yeah you don't you just
don't get to just run amuck and get away
with repercussions are real
you don't just just get do what you want
it makes sense why you gotta drink dash
in your face yeah it makes it you don't
get to just do what you want with no
repercussions like if you want to live
lavish and smash all the goals in the
world
you have to even relocate or tread
softly or you have to maneuver these
things sensitively because if you're
just going to move reckless then [ __ ] is
going to happen yeah that's just karma
yeah even whether you think of like
like they should know it's just sex or
whatever yeah life the universe doesn't
work like that it doesn't matter you
don't just get to win the lottery every
night yeah it just doesn't pay it just
doesn't work like that it doesn't
there's only so much luck you get and if
you're just going to be draws in all the
then bro yeah you're gonna have to deal
with the consequences i dealt with those
consequences back in cough when i was on
a hot streak bro
if the there's a couple times the wrong
girl saw me moving reckless and it got
sour
it got sour fast i was there you were
there i paid for it yeah i [ __ ] paid
for it i paid for some of them as well i
paid performance as well um and rightly
so i deserve to pay for it man you don't
just get to do what you want and get
away with it yeah yeah um
so yeah bro it's one of them ones it's
like
yes you kind of should have set the
precedent that
it is what it is but at the same time
i don't know a single guy
that would get moved to by a girl in a
night out get dragged back to their yard
so you say i'm sure you had some part to
play but i i don't if it's exactly how
you painted it which i doubt it is but
if it is
if a girl moved to me in a night out
drive me back to a yard we banged
and then i'm moving
reckless the next week
like we said i would expect her to just
firm the hell
and you can't
you don't have a right to say nothing to
me these girls don't have a right to do
these things to you i'm not saying that
you deserve it yeah i'm just saying
there's consequences to this
relationship of course yeah the streets
are unforgiving yeah they're relentless
yeah you don't get to just do what you
want
um
but yeah maybe you should have set some
kind of it depends
if you're doing it every week and it's
happening more than once then that's
your own fault of course you're if
you're the you're part of your own
product yeah if you if you've got if
you've been beefed more than once for
doing the same [ __ ] then it's all your
fault and you deserve everything
you deserve everything bro if one girl
comes up to you and says what the [ __ ]
and then you're like oh what i thought
you knew
and then she's like now what the [ __ ]
etc etc and then the very next week you
try it again and then the week from the
girl from the week before does the same
thing
what are you doing bro this is your
problem this is your problem now yeah um
and this full weighting
fam you're a light you're either a liar
or it's three brands and one girl
it's three breaths and one girl man said
he's patterned a friendship group for
friday saturday and sunday yeah he said
he banged his way through a friendship
group on friday saturday and sunday
friendship where are you meeting these
girls to be fair he said it's from my
ends okay
so
if he's from my ends
i'm not really sure specifically what
and i'm not trying to bait him out
either yeah i'm not really sure
specifically what ends he's referring to
but if he said you're old ends yeah i'm
thinking of but then again he might not
know what's my audience what my current
ends is or whatever
so if he's
if he's at where i think he's at then i
100
can see how he's scooping up this level
of pom
hundred percent okay because like you
said he's in a town where there's only
really one spot to go which makes me
think i know what enzy's talking about
and one million was that's what we used
to go to quite a bit
no no no no no no no no
no okay no no no i know what you're
talking about but no okay um
i think no i think he's talking about a
different time
maybe i think okay i think i know oh
actually
he might be talking about not the same
spot we went to the same time same town
okay
um and yeah for his age yeah there is
kind of one or two spots that you can go
to and oh yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah you'll scoop up oh sailor you'll
scoop up say less you'll scoop up and it
makes sense about like friday saturday
sunday yeah you're just there yeah scoop
up thing um
so yeah bro um
i don't know what to tell you really you
either either get strict with your
movements and make this a professional
sport or you keep running around like an
amateur and get drink stashed in your
face that's the truth it's literally up
to you
try your luck in a different city see
how good you are
that's when you know you yeah because
you sound like really big
hit the road go bollywood brom yeah you
need to become a road dog that's what we
did we learned that the hard way we got
comfortable in coventry yeah we got
comfortable in it we took it to the big
city we spread our wings yeah we learned
real quick it's not about that yeah
humble pipe yeah
these big man there was [ __ ] on you fam
you don't know about these local man
yeah yeah because you're doing bits in
your local town
try and compete against local man
in their local town
it's a different story you feel you
think you're building rapport with the
thing no man will click his fingers and
say come here she scatters off
heals
off
heartbreaking
where the world might you but you're on
your little run now enjoy it embrace it
because it's not going to stay like that
forever my dog yeah it's really not it
is what it is but uh yeah you are kind
of all the [ __ ] kind of not it's a
tough one but anyway guys
sorry we bored you for the last half an
hour with fight talk unless you like
fart talk and i hope you enjoyed it uh
but guys end of the year love love love
see you on thursday
[Music]